since we launched our emergency omicron
appeal on sunday night a great national
fight back has begun and people have
responded with an amazing spirit of duty
and obligation to others and i want to
say that each and every one of you who
rolls up your sleeve to get jabbed
is helping this national effort and i
want to thank everyone who has come
forward whether you've had to queue
around the block at a walk-in center or
whether you booked online
and of course on behalf of the whole
country i want to thank our nhs our gps
our pharmacists who with barely a day's
notice 48 hours notice have so
accelerated the program that we began
this week with the biggest vaccination
monday ever in england
and yesterday
the biggest booster day yet with more
than 650 000 boosters delivered across
the whole uk
in total we've boosted more than 45
percent of all adults in england
including more than 88
of those of those aged 70 or over
and while hospital admissions are going
up nationwide we're starting to see
admissions coming down
among some of the more vulnerable older
age groups where we've already got those
boosters in arms
from tomorrow we're speeding things up
even further by removing the 15-minute
post-vaccination waiting time
and while we're at it from monday
12 to 15 year olds can book in for a
second jab and we know how crucial it is
to keep children in school so let's all
make sure our children and young people
are vaccinated before they go back next
term
let's
slow down omicron's spread and at the
same time let's reduce the harm omicron
can do to us by building up our vaccine
defenses we're jabbing in hospitals
we're jabbing in surgeries we're jabbing
in pharmacies and in pop-up centers
we're jabbing in shopping centers and on
high streets in football stadiums with
mass events planned at stanford bridge
and wembley this weekend and
daily jabathons at elland road in leeds
we are throwing everything at it and
wherever you are
we'll be there
with a jab for you so please
get boosted now